hello and welcome i am james murphy from
mcoding.io and today we are re-covering
a problem that i've covered in a previous
video. the problem that we're covering again
is the first missing integer problem. last time i
covered this problem i solved it using python and
i took advantage of one of the problem constraints
that the input array size is at most 300
and because i really took advantage of that
constraint the solution that i came up with
wouldn't really work if you had much bigger
array sizes. so today i'm redoing it in c++
and i'm going to be using an algorithm that
will work for whatever array size you want so
just to recap the problem we're given an input
array like this 3 4 -1 1 5 and we're supposed
to find the smallest positive integer that
is not in the list so in this case we have 1
is there but 2 isn't so the algorithm should
return 2. the way that i'm solving it this
time is going to be a lot better than last time
because i'm not going to use extra space that
depends on the size of the nums array so this
algorithm will work no matter how big nums is.
additionally it's going to scan through
the array at most twice. so here's the idea
for each slot in the array imagine
the number that should be there.
so in this case first we see a 3 and the 3
is supposed to go here so let's put a 3 here.
now we clobbered this value
-1 in order to put the 3 there
but -1 is outside of the range
of numbers that we care about.
so during this algorithm whenever we encounter a
number that's outside the range that we care about
we just ignore it or we stop what we're doing
and move on to the next iteration. okay so the
next iteration we go through and we see 4.
4 is supposed to go here so we put 4 there.
now we had to displace 1 in order to put the 4
there and we do care about 1 so let's continue
the process with the 1. 1 is supposed to
go in this location so let's put it there.
and we had to displace a 3 in order to do
that so we go to where 3 should be and we see
that 3 is already there so we stop. then
we continue on to the next iteration
which is here. we see a 3 which is
already in the right place so we move on.
we see a 4 already in the right place so we move
on. we see a 5 already in the right place so we
move on and then we hit the end of the array.
we're done with the first pass, notice now that
any element in the array that we care about is
in the correct position, so all we have to do is
scan through the array and see if the number that
we find at that position is the correct number.
we look at the first position and we see a 1--
that's correct-- so we move on then we look at
the second position, and we see a 4 but we're
supposed to see a 2. if there was a 2 in this
array it would have moved to this position so
there must not be a 2 in the array so we can stop
and return 2 as the answer. this is an amazingly
simple and fast algorithm that gets the job done
so let's switch over to vs
code and code the solution.
so first we just make a loop over the array.
if you're wondering why i'm using longs here
the problem statement says that the ints that
are in this vector can be all the way up to the
maximum possible int to the minimum possible
int and so since we're going to be doing plus
or minus 1 kind of things i went ahead and made
these longs in order to avoid overflow issues.
next we just check for the current element that
we're looking at, is the index a valid index,
so current minus one is the index that current
should go in since we're only looking for positive
integers and not non-negative integers the index
corresponding to current is just current minus
one. this checks to see if current minus one is a
valid index and then this checks to see whether we
have looped back on ourselves. so if current were
equal to next then there's nothing more to do.
then inside this while loop all we do is put
current into the location that it's supposed to
go and then uh replace it with next. after this
for loop all of the positive integers that were
in the vector are now in the right places then
we just loop through the vector again and look
for the first index for which uh the thing at that
index is not equal to what's supposed to be there.
of course it's possible that we never return
from this return statement, everything is in
its rightful place, so the first missing thing
is the first thing that's outside of the range.
so that would be the length of the vector plus
one. all right so i went ahead and submitted it
uh it says the run time was zero milliseconds,
faster than 100% of c ++ online submissions
for this problem. so i can't imagine that
no one else has come up with this solution
and that this is actually the fastest code
that has ever been run for this question,
i'm guessing just that anything less than one
millisecond is deemed zero milliseconds and so a
whole bunch of good answers get lumped as exactly
100%. so there you have it there's my second take
at the first missing in problem with a much better
solution. i hope you enjoyed this one a lot more
than the last one and if you did don't forget to
like comment and subscribe, see in the next one